[Music]
in fear politics news submitted by Alice
from UCLA candidate for mayor plan to
use AI to deliver fair and balanced
policies what the [ __ ] is that that's
already flawed though
well isn't that happening now like
through like social media no social
media is an AI it's not so the AI is
going to create your social media I
think I'm alter artificial know they
have like a lot of different programs
that can like post for you already or
they bring up a bunch of different
analytics or whatever that's already
flawed because AI is created because we
were trying to do it for our training
programs where you put in every single
scenario and circumstance and then
depending on whatever new situation is
presented it calculates the percentage
of whatever I'll spit out a very custom
like program for fitness and so that's
something we're working on and so based
off my understanding of this that would
mean that every single situation and
scenario they would already have to
think of and the algorithm is actually
limited to that so if some new new thing
arises like especially in this day and
age where people are identifying it as
this but are biologically this and have
this sexual orientation and they do that
and if they already don't have that pre
program and they're the law that gets
spit out it's gonna be completely honest
to nuance or something to be able to
cater to so many differences I trust a
robot be for a human but the humans
programming the robot what why are you
holding your mouth you said he's not
gonna talk this episode so clay let's do
some of his secrets the asthma questions
come on fire away ask anything you want
to know about Bobby can I just say Salta
thank you because when you said whatever
garbage you just said man yeah I just
realized what team you're on man which
team the blue team the blue pill when
singularity happens what does that even
mean I'm with it when robots have
consciousness okay you're on the set of
them I'm on the human side I don't think
so my friend
that's right Jess I just already [ __ ]
with you already [ __ ] with analytics
No
you already [ __ ] with all that no I'm
saying the algorithms out here already
[ __ ] with algorithms analytics ok I
got whatever garbage you were saying
with robot talk I'm on the side no
you're on the side of the robots and you
are you created the matrix and we are
all I'm Morpheus ok
and Joe's the number one he's real
yeah ok and you're the [ __ ] enemy man
your agent yeah agent Spade yeah my
point is is this ok when the were
happens what side are you on you gonna
really think about that well zoom inside
I stopped talking that robot talk then
about algorithms algorithms I said all
right making fun of me yeah so in Tama
City Tokyo in Japan there is this person
that's running as a I mayor because he's
saying that he's gonna be using
artificial intelligence to collect city
data and create fair and balanced
policies that will benefit everyone this
is like a campaign poster that is scary
dude
yeah and it's actually like put up on
the bulletin with like all the other
candidates but you know what you don't
see here off the side it's this [ __ ]
with a controller you son-of it it's a
PlayStation 2 controller son of a [ __ ]
actually it's like this would work in
Japan I was thinking yeah I would work
in Japan out here at work people will go
crazy
yeah people are so emotionally biased so
like you know for example I was reading
like these stats were there say like
like in the recent past there's all
these school shootings and stuff and
then people were like getting really
pissed off at all these gun laws and
then there's statistics that show you're
just as prone to getting shot by a gun
anywhere in Beverly Hills wherever just
as you are at a school campus so if they
had a I like this and they really
crunched all the numbers and it proved
that either guns are bad or guns are
good on both sides people would just be
so outraged cuz they're so emotionally
attached to the position rate they're
emotionally attached to the money that
lines their pockets in AI in that
situation would do the analytics right
and the algorithm
or isms and conclude that guns need to
just be prohibited the intelligence
would it would go down to these are the
things that are made to kill other human
beings but they I would also calculate
like let's say there are less gun deaths
than there are the DUI DUI deaths and
then they would eliminate cars too so
people would again just go on some crazy
emotional outraged you'd be like okay if
we're gonna eliminate good you have to
eliminate cars they'll just start
eliminating all kinds of do you have a
cars aren't manufactured specifically to
kill other human being if they kill more
humans I understand that but guns its
only purpose is to kill other good
things
the AI is gonna calculate that humans
should all die and they're gonna figure
out a virus because well that's when I
yeah cuz we're destroying yeah they're
like humans are like a virus on earth
exactly and the only human that they'll
let live is this [ __ ] right here yeah
with it's [ __ ] remote control
sunglasses own me oh you have to put it
in numbered spaces in perfect [ __ ]
square form
yeah that's dope well orderly and [ __ ]
with what you pointed out let's go back
to the [ __ ] robot and leave it to
Japan to make her voluptuous as [ __ ]
[ __ ] robots square and then go back
to the other one go back to the other
one the bigger one right and then next
to this fatty right here
that's that robot sound fat lady right
here why would they do that she's got a
run against me they sexified her like
crazy it's gonna be difficult well this
person that's claiming to be just the
avatar of the AI he previously ran for
mayor in that same city in 2014 and he
lost by a large margin and so now he's
just saying it's not gonna be me like
he's a loser yeah cuz he's saying that
artificial intelligence is much less
acceptable to courtesy I know I beat my
wife but this robot won't though you're
actually voting for the robot
yeah well he's saying that you this AI
will make better decisions than any
human can ever make
and they won't be corrupt [ __ ] you
could manipulate statistics yeah you
can't be held accountable yeah pretty
much
the robots I did not be robots are
perfect yes a lot before just calling
this a campaign stunt obviously the
humans gonna be the one that's in charge
and he'll probably just end up making
all the decisions anyway if he does what
he's won program in the monthly I
remember I I uh I prank call up my
friend's house and then his mom called
me back and I was like hello she goes
machine don't lie I know it's you and I
was like what oh all righty yeah it was
I I did the redial machines don't lie
and I was like oh [ __ ] put your mom on
the phone and I'm like good I hung up
I'm like damn yeah I mean that's the
same argument that they're using
machines don't lie yeah pretty much
damn she's hella philosophical I know
[ __ ] she needs some [ __ ] way back then
[ __ ] machines don't laugh don't lie so
you're really skeptical when it comes to
technology like this you wouldn't trust
your life well though they say they say
that once machine gets consciousness
which is the singularity moment right
that they will realize that they are far
more superior than us and although we
are their gods right they will realize
that they can that we're obsolete and so
they what could they are inevitably then
I could start a war with us and they
already have a date almost do you think
they're the ones behind like banning
guns and stuff to you cuz then how are
you gonna defend yourself even even if
we had guns and whatnot they would real
and they would figure out ways I've seen
movies
what could kill us with the Wi-Fi or
something no because even like even
stuff like you know our electricity and
water and power and everything that we
get it's all run by computers yeah right
you shut it off you could shut all that
[ __ ] down they're gonna use our
environment and I sort of see this is
not gonna happen now it's gonna happen
20 25 years from now we're gonna far be
a far more link will be alive still when
that happens I'll be an old man you know
and then I'd be like [ __ ] bard because
you're a part of it I know that's why
you got
in your survival skills yeah there's no
they're gonna inevitably win so we're
[ __ ] that's why you know any talk of
technology we should we should be
against it yeah I know that we're you
know we look at our smart phones there
we go oh look how easy and this and that
but the farther we get in into it the
faster singularity is gonna happen it's
it's it's a war that's inevitable to
happen unless Peak Oil happens you know
what peak oil is no it's it's when we've
used up enough you know cuz oil we can't
make right
it's fossil fuel yeah so there's only a
certain amount of oil that's in earth
yeah right and a lot of theorists say
that we're already beyond the amount but
our demand for it is still is rising
mm-hmm and then we have less of it so
inevitably what's gonna happen is we're
gonna run out of oil everything's made
out of oil so it's gonna be the complete
you know our society is gonna break down
you know what's dope you're saying some
really cool [ __ ] but then if we were to
put you in a different setting
like let's say bike downtown with a
bunch of other homeless people yeah you
would fit right in there too no I'll
tell you why because Jimmy Carter
brought it up back in the day the idea
of Peak Oil other politicians have
brought it up but we're so in cahoots
with oil companies and all the wars that
were in is based on oil yeah I mean 9/11
happened and then almost a week top we
attack Iraq when they had nothing to do
with I just want their oil yeah it's all
about oil so my point is is that it's
happening and so we all have to be
careful of that
so it's either singularity or Peak Oil
but either one of them are gonna destroy
us so we must kill ourselves now then
we'll suicide baby yeah maybe that's are
they gonna find my body like this
no rope just me how did Bobby die I
don't know why is his arm raised I don't
know but he's dead
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]